Speaker 1: We now have also learned not only about
a police officer, not only about an anti vaccine
police officer, but an anti vaccine police captain
who was taking ivermectin to combat covid-19 has
died of covid-19. This is being reported by Yahoo!
News. A Georgia police officer who frequently
posted anti vaccine messages on Facebook and
took an anti parasitic drug instead of a vaccine
has died of covid-19 Captain Joe Manning, 57 years
old. Remember, we're not talking about 80 year
olds here. Last guy, Marc Bernier, was sixty five.
This police captain was 57. Captain Joe Manning,
57, of the Wayne County Sheriff's Office, died
on Wednesday after a short battle with the virus.
Sheriff Chuck Mosley said Captain Manning was
an integral part of our family and our hearts
are broken. Our love and prayers go forward to
his family. Would have been nice to include a
get the vaccine, keep your families safe. After
the announcement of his death, Facebook posts
made by Manning circulated on social media. He
posted a couple of different things summarized
here by Ken Bernstein. I am not vaccinated by
choice, and that's my right. He posted that
Joe Manning truth. It's not the government's job
to protect my health. It's the government's job
to protect my rights. Of course, everything
is misspelled. It is no apostrophes. It's my
job to protect my health. When you trade for
liberty, when you trade, liberty for safety,
you end up losing both. OK, folks, Wayne Feed
and Seed has some liquid and paste ivermectin
get it while supplies last, he was promoting
ivermectin and he has now died of covid-19.
This is I still see this as a tragedy. I
don't see this and go. What a great thing.
Now, many of you have been writing in and
saying, David, this might actually start
to affect elections if you have Republicans not
getting vaccinated at higher rates than Democrats.
That means you're going to have Republicans dying
at higher rates than Democrats at a certain point.
This could lead to Republicans losing some seats
because too many of their voters are dying. You're
absolutely right. And if that happens, that's
going to happen and it'll be good for Democrats.
But I still take no pleasure in the death and
suffering of people. There are, you know, some
of these people. Tomorrow, we're going to talk
about Caleb Wallace, the militia and Hamas militia
dude who died of covid as much of a prick as he
might be, as much of a doofus as he might be,
as much of a terrible person as he might be. He
left behind kids and a widow. And at least as
far as the kids are concerned, this is not their
fault. And now they are left without a dad because
of this. So it's very hard for me to take pleasure
in that. But I recognize at a certain point
the numbers could actually get so lopsided in
terms of Republicans versus Democrats dying that
it could affect some races. And in fact, the math
of it is that if this continues being really bad
in Florida for another six to eight months, you
could actually have a partizan gap in Florida,
bigger in terms of deaths than Rhonda Sanders's
margin of victory in twenty eighteen. I've looked
at the numbers before. I'll explain the numbers
again. That's not for today. Let's take a quick
break. We'll follow up on the Caleb Wallace thing
tomorrow, but much more upcoming in mere moments.